if you need any indication of the
direction movies are going in this fall
well Lego Batman said it best darkness
no parents from a girl with the Dragon
Tattoo sequel to a long-awaited first
look at the conjuring spinoff / prequel
the nirn June is promising a Halloween
season that will have you cowering under
the covers that said it's not all doom
and gloom on the docket June also
brought us trailers for Ralph breaks the
Internet the Peter Jackson produced
immortal engines and the Transformers
spin-off bumblebee to name a few in fact
we're looking at incredible trailers for
movies as far out as 2019 which means
there are a lot to run through here are
all the trailers from June 2018 for
movies that are sure to blow you away
Siberia Keanu Reeves as front and center
in the first trailer for Siberia a crime
thriller about a sketchy diamond
smuggler who heads to Russia to look for
his missing partner there he discovers
that his partner was trying to cheat
some terrifyingly serious Russian
mobsters will he be able to make it out
of Siberia in one piece or will he find
himself on the wrong side of Russian
justice
find out when Siberia lands and theaters
on July 13th poor boy
to be honest poor boy doesn't look like
an instant classic the story of two
hustlin brothers who concoct a scheme to
finally get out of there nowhere town
the film had a few festivals in 2016 and
then disappeared until it's secured a
2018 release date the highlight of the
trailer has to be Michael Shannon and
rodeo clown makeup delivering slow
existential quotes while he takes long
drags on his cigarettes hopefully that
won't be the only reason to see poor boy
but even if it is well there are worse
ways to spend an afternoon
look for it on July 13th Robin Williams
come inside my mind what can you say
about Robin Williams that hasn't been
said before I do a great impression of a
hot dog he entertained the decades of
fans and now HBO is releasing a
documentary about Williams life two
twists a faucet on those tear ducts one
more time with a wealth of
behind-the-scenes footage photographs
from his childhood and interviews with
Williams friends and family Robin
Williams come inside my mind looks like
an intimate glimpse into the life of the
legendary comic there you are you become
a reformed alcoholic you've got a
steaming glass of Perrier
and I feel so much better about that
take a look when it premieres on HBO on
July 16th alpha the story of a dog and
his prehistoric boy alpha is having no
trouble tugging of viewers heartstrings
with his trailer full of sweeping music
and touching moments alphas trailers
billet as a movie about the
domestication of dogs think of it as a
gritty origin story of your mom's Corgi
and okay that may not seem like gripping
cinema at first glance but alpha might
just pull it off through spectacle alone
the trailer reveals rich cinematography
filled with gorgeous landscapes and
soaring aerial shots throw in a story
about two sad wolf and you've got your
hands on cinematic gold look for alpha
on August the 17th the little stranger
with 2015's room director Lennie
Abramson made a unique gut-wrenching
movie about a mother who would go to any
lens to protect her son the first
trailer for his upcoming the little
stranger reveals another subtle nerve
jarring ride this time with a
supernatural twist the story centers on
a small-town doctor played by domhnall
gleeson who's called out to an old
estate to fix up a sick made it isn't
long before the old house begins
revealing disturbing secrets suggesting
a supernatural presence the little
stranger is based on the 2009 gothic
novel of the same name and arrives in
theaters on August 31st the nirn the
creepy evil known phallic made her first
appearance on the conjuring 2 and the
nun will serve as something of an origin
story for the demon with the main story
centered on a romanian priest and the
young nun who are investigating what
happened to an urn in an old church it
looks like a delightfully eerie popcorn
movie to check out this fall the nun
hits theaters on September 7th Monday he
is what we figured out from the trailer
for Monday if losing your mind was a
color it be Nic Cage in neon pink with a
homemade battle axe
it's crazy evil the story of a man and a
girl living in the woods who get
targeted by a sadistic biker cult mandy
is somewhere between an acid trip and a
horror movie
the perfect platform for Nic Cage to let
loose with whatever it is that Nic Cage
lets loose with take a look when Mandy
barrels into theatres on September 14th
the old man and the gern Robert Redford
headlines his upcoming crime film as an
old man who knocks over banks by
flashing a gun and a smile the old man
and the gun is based on the real life of
Forrest Tucker a career criminal who
escaped from prison nearly 20 times the
events of the film followed Tucker as an
elderly man who's still pulling Heights
enchanting the bank workers with his
gentlemanly smile even as he makes off
with thousands in cash he had a girl who
saw well he was also shortened to
gentlemen Robert Redford is perfectly
cast to play a suave elderly criminal
and with Casey Affleck [ __ ] Spacek and
Danny Glover co-starring the old man and
the gun looks like a guaranteed winner
look for it on September 28th bad times
at the El Royale when seven strangers
show up at a seedy hotel near Lake Tahoe
the meeting kicks off a fateful night
when nothing is what it seems as the
hours in the hotel we're on each of them
reveals a dark secret
I'm not really apprec-- written and
directed by Drew Goddard who also held
the charm a twisting cabin in the woods
bad times at the El Royale is a tour de
force of star power Jeff Bridges Chris
Hemsworth Dakota Johnson and Jon Hamm
headline the film and the brief trailer
hits all the right beats without giving
away any plot twists check into the El
Royale when the movie lands in theaters
on October 12th first man directed by
the oscar-winning director of la-la land
first man centers on a young Niall
Armstrong
during the lead-up to the Apollo 11
mission to land on the moon of course
it's safe to say that we know how the
story will end but the dramatized
version of the momentous event coupled
with Ryan Gosling's portrayal of
Armstrong should be enough to keep
audiences on the edge of their seats
look for first man to land on October
12th serenity
Matthew McConaughey stars in his
upcoming thriller as a quiet fishing
boat captain who gets an unexpected
visit from his ex-wife played by Anne
Hathaway she has a simple request take
her current husband out on the water and
leave him for the Sharks after
the trailer grinds into gear throwing
out tantalizing glimpses of the story or
the slow tick of a fishing reel drives
up the tension if the movie is anywhere
near as good as the trailer
serenity looks like a shore wind to look
forward to later this year check it out
when it reaches theaters on October 19th
Ralph breaks the Internet the story of
an arcade villain who decides that he
wants to become a hero 2012's wreck-it
Ralph is both an awesome love letter to
video games and the heartfelt adventure
tale and where are you coming from
pac-man yeah bring any fruit with you no
no no fruit okay there if the trailer
for the sequel is any indication it's
heading in the same direction after a
worryingly emoji movie ask opening that
sees Ralph and vanellope travel to the
Internet and gaze out over a sprawling
city of product placement the trailer
finds its tried vanellope ends up in a
room full of Disney Princesses they
escaped from stormtroopers and it all
looks like a lot of fun
check out Ralph breaks the internet on
November 21st shouldn't be Ralph Rex the
Internet yes and he is wreck-it Ralph
yeah but break the Internet it's like a
pain the girl in the spider's web
Sony seems to have a plan for their
adaptations of the Millennium book
series even if nobody else can figure it
out
trailing David Fincher's 2011 The Girl
with the Dragon Tattoo and a complete
critically acclaimed trilogy of Swedish
film adaptations Sony is replacing the
entire cast and moving straight to the
fourth novel the girl in the spider's
web to be fair though this new take
looks like it's in good hands
don't brief Eddie Alvarez is directing
with Golden Globe winner Claire Foy
stepping in as Jaco vigilante Lisbeth
Salander look for it in theaters on
November 9th created to Michael B Jordan
is returning to the ring this year in
Creede to the trailer seats Creed
training harder than ever or balancing
his family life at all ends of a
tantalizing glimpse of Ivan Drago's son
promising an epic emotional fight the
first Creed film became a surprise hit
when it was released in 2015
resulting in an Oscar nomination for
Best Supporting Actor for Sylvester
Stallone and the major box-office take
Creed - looks like it's following in the
same footsteps look for it on November
21st
welcome to Marwan Steve Carell stars and
welcome to Marwan as mark Hogan camp an
artist who lost his ability to draw
after me was beaten by neo-nazis through
extensive detailed miniature models mark
channels his imagine
into a new form of arts dolls now pants
blue and sometimes his imagination takes
him straight into the stories of the
dolls themselves
welcome to Marwin looks like one of the
most unique movies to hit theaters in
2018 take a look when it premieres on
November 21st mortal engines the
oscar-winning screenwriting team behind
the Lord of the Rings is taking on
another epic adaptation this December
with mortal engines apart ik tale about
wheeled cities that Rove around the land
preying on weaker cities the story
centers on a young woman named has to
shore who becomes a fugitive from the
rolling city of London after she
attempts to assassinate a powerful man
named Valentine the trailer sets up the
premise beautifully while leaving the
main meat of the story for the movie
itself look for mortal engines on
December 14th Bumblebee eleven years and
five movies after kids first fell in
love with HD robot toys the Transformers
franchise is getting back to its roots
bumblebee sees the magical beginnings of
the yellow car alien known as dwell
bumblebee back when he was just a humble
a VW Bug in a dusty scrapyard Hailee
Steinfeld starts as a human girl who
discovers him kicking off a new
adventure that sees the unlikely duo on
the run from the evil government and the
evil of robots sort of like the first
movie if all the people were a place of
different people take a look when
bumblebee transforms and rolls into
theaters in December 2018
the lego movie - the second part bricks
burgers and dire straights in the first
trailer for the lego movie - which sees
the town of lego people transformed into
a post-apocalyptic wasteland but
desolate ruins and super babies aren't
enough to get Emma down he's still the
cheerful naive guy he always was master
builder or not the lego movie - the
second part is scheduled to hit theaters
in February 2019 damn beau continuing
their ongoing march of live-action
remakes Disney release their first
trailer for Dumbo this June the journey
of a little circus elephant who gets
picked on until he learns how to fly
it's definitely a story that's been
enchanting kids for generations the new
trailer doesn't go into much of the
story instead focusing on the essence of
the tale which is nothing short of pure
childhood magic look for it in theaters
in March 2019 thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you love to
[Music]